today's topic one bachelor looking for
love will meet five potential matches
here's the catch some of them are lying
and trying to win a cash prize can our
bachelor eliminate gold diggers and try
to find a true match or will they just
get played this is love or money
well hello guys welcome to love or money
this is the gay edition any thoughts
before we start
let me ask you what
what percentage of our viewers have
already clicked off the video
i'm gonna give it like 25 that's
possible yeah if you're one of those
guys you're gonna click off because were
like
sodomy right like if you're one of those
guys okay
we have we are about to pass legislation
to find out what gays do in the privacy
of their bedroom okay abba why are you
gay
yeah if you're one of those guys leave a
comment below no they already clicked on
i've taken time to do a little research
to find out what gays do in the privacy
of their bedroom huh and they have a
practice called enoli king
where another man's rectum is leaked and
poo poo is coming out huh and he's
licking it like ice cream huh yes
yes this is a parental guidance moment
that child can be removed yes that helps
they have another practice
called fisting where a man's hand is
inserted into another man's anus
and it is so painful they have to take
drugs but they enjoy it
huh headshot look at this one
staggerfulizer
and we have to ask barack obama is this
what he wants to bring to uganda as a
human rights ambassador huh
for our children to eat the poo-poo
classic i don't know why i did that
whole thing you did the whole [ __ ] i've
i've watched that video ten years ago
who hit though if you don't know what
this video is go watch eat the poopoo
okay this it's a real title
e a t
duh
[Applause]
youtube it you're welcome but you don't
kill me about that video yeah
the guy goes this is a parental guidance
moment and it's already halfway through
the whole disgusting part yeah
yeah you already said that here is your
beautiful bachelor you want to go ahead
and introduce yourself what's up guys
i'm bijan i'm excited to be here and i'm
very nervous what's his name
it's like
not the most yeah
yeah yeah
you know a little bit of a bad [ __ ]
energy oh bison
oh bison yeah yeah oh bishow
okay okay you know what's funny
what makes dijon spicy
which is well if you translate okay fall
it's really
heart crying
strong crack
this is one of those uncle jokes yeah
and they just laugh at it and the laugh
makes you laugh but i laugh like an
uncle you know how you transfer that
[ __ ] it's that fall but if you translate
it in english you know what it is
strong crack
hold up raise your leg high don't forget
to see it
you're impeccable if you think my
ugandan pastor accent is good your old
geezer uncle accident is fantastic hey
look at that boy what what come here man
you know what you know you know what
makes monsters messy
it's that ball but if if you translate
that
it's strong crap
oh
yes
look at the ties on that one
he's like a horse he could kick for days
i work at tao are you familiar i love
tao what are you doing i work there i
know do you want okay i'm a server
that's cute it's so cute do you give
people your numbers well it's a very
like hetero environment unfortunately
same with my clubs but i'm not above
giving someone my number i would
absolutely do that do it yeah and you
should give me your number oh my god
all right
i'm gonna appreciate how they get it
they they do it they go in they don't
they don't [ __ ] around you don't [ __ ]
around even if you look at this like uh
my children would never eat the poo poo
even if you if you come from that you
have to appreciate the fact that they're
going for yo both the contestants and
the the guys you know i mean i
appreciate that so remember when we were
watching uh you know larp girl and
whatever there was a blank silence you
mean we were watching [ __ ] paint dry
yeah were we watching ice melts were we
were watching sand blowing the wind yes
i remember that [ __ ] what the [ __ ] do i
remember that [ __ ] because it happens
every day and it's forgetful so i know
what happened yesterday [ __ ] and that's
what happened the day before and it's
gonna happen tomorrow what the [ __ ] is
up with your enemies no but i've been on
too many dry dates to be like yo i'm if
i'm not if i was gay that life would be
easier plus
i'm glad i'm not
you know i mean what i meant to say was
big balls i'm tied to elizabeth and
that's why i can't you know because i
would be betrayed is she entitled to you
yo bro
why is it every time i bring this [ __ ]
up you can't you find a way to try to
try to jab i'm just giving you the truth
okay but stop it don't you like this you
no i don't oh it's about your feelings
facts don't care about your feelings
okay
okay ben shapiro facts facts actually
you know the thing is facts care
feelings care about your banana that's
the thing that's happening and and it
gets significantly significantly more
vulgar uh and it gets significantly
significantly more vulgar okay listen
okay sure
[Laughter]
is in this house there's some horses
there's some horrors
yeah i like bear i actually like i think
ben is like
accidentally funny it's not even his
fault yeah it's not his fault
but you know what i appreciate he could
laugh at himself yes which you know what
makes it enjoyable even if he has some
[ __ ] he takes some time i enjoy his
content let's take a break for two
seconds shall we hmm how you feeling
anxious
i get it i mean this past year has been
horrible for some
and then you want to get outside to you
know get your cannabis to lower your
anxiety but you're afraid to go outside
because you have too much anxiety which
creates more anxiety
and that defeats the purpose abba and
preach we got your back and for that we
present to you the company called radix
and they just want to bring cannabis at
your house without you having to get out
you can't focus because you're home you
need to get stuff done you can't boom
neuro root huh all plant babies cannabis
babies it's wonderful you're too anxious
you can't go to sleep insomnia is a
mother they got your back too they have
the sleepy bears part cbd part melatonin
they got everything you need you don't
even know if you're not even sure what
you want to do or what you want to get
you can be part of cannabis cornstarch
club from radix they send you every
month little samples of everything
get on it and get in the website the
website is www.radixremedies.com
abba and preach enter a promo called
preach 15 to get 15 percent off your
cannabis connoisseur club
and then get your samples every month
now back to normal scheduled programming
i like fun guys well i'm gonna turn
dijon around and you guys have envelopes
and markers underneath your stools you
guys can grab them and you're gonna
write whether you're in it for love or
money do you have any expectations for
today i was recently in love with this
dude
you know what sounds like drama
karma
there was no other way that sent this
was going to end like
i don't know
it was either that it was the frost i
was like where's this going it was like
it was either that or an insult for sure
for sure i was in love with this
and during that time i realized oh yeah
i am ready to settle down i just haven't
met the right guy now what are your
names liam liam purnell brunell
pronounced purnell david david nico nico
and i'm ori ori yeah how do you spell
that o-h-r-y the h is silent though well
so far i like your energy the most what
yeah you haven't said anything what
about this energy a little a little
pensive maybe a little ancient
what's mine
oreo
yeah i'm not gonna front you i feel like
gay guys can get away with murder yes
they can they can say anything that they
want to each other egregious [ __ ] yeah
they can even say it to straight people
egregious [ __ ] yeah and they do yeah
they do
[ __ ]
oh yeah it's bad
didn't get away with all that yeah yes
but it could they could even they go
worse than that yeah yeah [ __ ] is just
entry level yeah they go worse oh look
at you little [ __ ]
y'all
i like this it's like kind of [ __ ]
you're kind of [ __ ] aren't you they
could get away with a lot of [ __ ] yeah
okay all right all right um where are
you from where are you all from chicago
chicago where are you from i was born in
los angeles but i grew up in grover
beach wait where did you grow up though
did you grow up in l.a i did not i did
not yeah i grew up in like buildings
yeah yeah what
what did you say i said nothing oh oh
yeah we'll talk a point there
i said not a great listener because you
said you were from grover beach and i
heard it the first time oh
yeah this guy's so like down down that
he's being a teacher's pen the [ __ ]
dating show uh not not listening what'd
you say huh huh no nothing no he's just
nothing you said that you grew up in
grover's beach and he wasn't listening
get rid of this [ __ ] loser and let's
go home together
did you just realize how gay you sounded
yeah you did that that's called getting
in cancer if i can do a [ __ ] anti-gay
pastor from from uganda you think i
can't do a gay dude from chicago
[Music]
you don't think i got the talent no you
called me a bad [ __ ] last episode but
you was a baby
like that
and shaking your shoulder you know what
me being a bad [ __ ] is just a matter of
empathy it's my ability to put myself in
other people's shoes and understand
their lived experiences
sorry adaptable yeah if you catch me in
a gay club i'm not talking undercover
yogurt
i don't know what that means that's
another
no there's sigma male there's alpha male
and there's yogurt
all right listen ligma males are
responsible did you feel a connection
with anyone yet i don't know see some of
them didn't talk so that's gonna help me
narrow my choices i like a talker do you
think you know who a liar is or yeah i
got to keep that on your mind i think
the kid on the on this or oreo or or
cory ori
i think he's a freaking liar
he's like too confident
if you want any indication that someone
doesn't like you they just make zero
effort to say your name correctly ori is
not complicated it's two syllables ori
this is oreo he's just adding extra
letters in there to be like [ __ ]
i'm not even gonna remember your name
i'm gonna make an extra effort not to
remember yeah yeah
you know what i actually appreciate
about this guy as in in comparison to
the other contestants he just says it
he's a [ __ ] liar and he's a fake and
i want to find love like i appreciate
that energy this is this is the best
episode so far and you know what
elizabeth has zero chemistry with this
guy and it's making me happy i feel
secure no cause she's raw dogging the
other dude
listen bro
you gotta stop [ __ ] doing that bro
stop bringing up alex
i looked him up
wow dude
samson sam sam sam simpson
and sam sam what was going on with that
banana stuff it felt like a comfort
thing like i could grip on to you know
i'm a little [ __ ] up like that but
you'll get to know that like a dirty
mind sometimes i'll tell you in the dms
how do you say your name abba
yeah can i get your number
[Music]
so do you know who you're gonna
eliminate i do
hi guys welcome back
all right bijan choose wisely i'm gonna
get totally in this
i'm sorry you're too quiet this is round
two where bijan will get deeper with his
potential matches are you ready to get
closer i'm ready to get deeper
i love that intellectually bars
mega paws parts i don't mind this
pause still it's kind of like you know
how gay guys get away with saying
anything like that but he knew he was he
knew
right like you know what i mean you know
they get away with that he can get away
with saying that to us
of course
nice to see you nice to see you all
right so grover beach yeah oh a good
memory
it's such teachers pets energy
yes you hated that i hate that [ __ ]
i hate grovelers
i hate guys who've been like i'm better
than others because i remember the
little things that i i hated that you
know what i mean like i can't stand that
[ __ ] yeah i can't stand that when they
want to treat for remembering it too
like [ __ ] still it's not even you know
what i hated back then yeah yeah it's
whenever that was christmas
christmas at the end of the year okay
and these [ __ ] brought a gift
yay
yo i'm gonna punch you in the mouth you
brought a gift you already have good
grades i can't even get i can't have bad
greatness i can't have bad grades and
bring a gift you know i mean yeah
there's level to this [ __ ] there's a lot
i mean
hi ori yeah okay let's get to the bottom
of this tell me why you don't trust me
you're a little too confident but you
know what i i like that though i do like
that i would prefer that you're
confident and not trust you
then trust you and you'd be boring this
is why i'm single okay we were like
talking in the green room uh-huh okay
can we guess what you do oh my god
you're probably like an influencer or
something i'm going to be a senior
undergrad at usc did you get in
legitimately to usc hopefully you look
like a fake rower to me
yeah but they nag all the time that's
what they do that's how they yeah i
don't matter he just roasted him with
his face like you look you look you have
rich white parents
that's what he's doing to you because
that's a good thing where'd you go to
school i went to george washington
university okay in dc right have you
ever seen that bridge where it's like
just like one way
and it's like the cars like you have to
stop on the other side to let the one
people come and then you go no crazy
bridge change the topic anyway okay no
wait are you not a beach person i am now
i usually go with my friends and get a
tan oh that was quick am i out okay bye
always a pleasure
is it like bijan or dijon
bijan the bee cool yeah everyone always
thinks my name is dijon you want to know
why it's because they think you're spicy
you don't be showing spicy mustard yeah
yeah it's good mustard actually okay so
i'm leaning towards ori you like his
vibe i like his vibe he seems like he's
fun and also serious i could marry niko
and i actually was like oh i wanted to
ask you another question he's a nice
person and do you think they're all in
it for love the young undergrad he might
be in it for money
yeah he's really performing he's young
eight years younger that's right but you
said that's hot it is kind of hot
can i can i appreciate
that
all you women at home just watched and
thought that was hilarious meanwhile if
this is a dude talking about a young
woman that way you'd be like
just saying just saying that's why i
said when i said gay guys can get away
with murders not just murder sometimes
do you know what i'm saying oh god
i just appreciate that i mean he's in
his 20s so it's not pedophilia i agree i
don't think i'm just saying but i know
but i know i know i know i don't
understand what you're saying but you
know 30. because i promise you if i went
to the youtube comments on the same
video but a straight couple there's no
way him
[Music]
all right so i enjoyed talking to
everybody
but
sounds good
i know did you not know there's gonna be
a couch i saw it over there surprise
this is a gosh so intimate i know
when was your last relationship i
actually uh got a relationship three
months ago and everything was going
perfectly i think it was a more
technical issue what does that mean it
was oh yeah
both of us could get it up
but
we both
needed
[Music]
we both needed somewhere to put it
what are you into
good day everyone my name is dr martin
senpai
and today we are here to talk about the
task force on
homosexuality and sodomy tops what are
you into
oh
we're going into that oh no
okay probably can you go first so i know
like what looks like the lines we're
going i know right
um
[Music]
maybe we should just move on to the next
okay
have you ever been in love yeah
when was that um the last time or like
just i need oh my god you've been in
love multiple times yeah i feel like you
can love multiple people you guys are
ready
yes yeah the moment has come
where bijan is going to decide who he
wants to go on another date with
do you know
no i don't know do you have an idea who
you're gonna pick
i like your
energy more
but i think i vibe with you a little bit
more so i think i'm gonna select
[Music]
i'll have you walk out over here
bijan do you think you saw past his
surface and solid true intentions i
think
and do you think you made the right
choice with whatever's in this envelope
i think you guys will see okay
if he chose money this [ __ ] is a
sociopath yeah that's cold
let's go yeah he'd be like [ __ ] i was
trouble yeah yeah he looks like that
that's my noob let's lie down let's lie
down
all right this is love or money
and here you go oh my god should i
present it out to the world
before i open this
i just want to say you're the most
amazing guy
and
my decision has
intention behind it
so it's not looking good
i think money
i deserve that but let me tell you why
oh actually because you chose money i
have to usher you off right away oh my
god you can't get his number socials
i'm sorry you have to go this way
i knew it
no you didn't you tried you knew it at
the end but hey man listen i'm not even
afraid this is the best episode so far
three for that was cold bad guys
let me just tell you guys something this
is why i tell you [ __ ] to settle okay
go for the less attractive person stay
away from white women you're gonna win
most of the time
did you not notice that pattern with all
the contestants who lost
they chose this more attractive one or
they chose the white women yeah he what
do you say he's a bad boy he's got the
energy though oh yeah
you're trying nice he called it just
what happens when you choose with your
your private parts you know what i'm
saying well so you don't want to set it
up
oh something you want to say that you
said last night
there's been enough dick energy in this
for i don't need to say it
dude
i'm so sad i know right you guys had
such good chemistry i really thought he
was in it for the love i don't think i
ever thought he was in it for the love
to be honest that's true the minute he
walked in you're like i have to watch
him i'm like he's true rubble i want him
[Music]
i did it and let me tell you why please
tell me why my sister just got her
master's degree i could take this
beautiful young man out to dinner or i
could take my sister who has literally
been taking care of me since i was two
years old
out to a dinner that she deserves for
working so hard and earning her degree
oh bijon is amazing guy like i honestly
wish that wasn't one or the other oh
you're so cute
okay it's okay take your sister out i
will send you guys all the pictures we
might go to tau maybe he will be your
waiter oh my gosh
i hope you really like your meal sister
now i'm gonna [ __ ] him
[Laughter]
i enjoyed that if you guys made through
this whole episode and it made you
uncomfortable good congratulations the
first step towards overcoming your fear
of gay folks just plain i don't think
you're actually afraid of gay folks i
think you just hate them
helps you get over that little hump you
know what i'm saying you're welcome and
you know at the end of the day do you
making it this far is a show of good
will you know congratulations good on
you got a you got a flag somewhere a
flag do like rainbows and stuff just
edit it
you know what i'm saying
um so
leave your comments below let us know
what you guys think about trans women in
bathrooms and that's it transforming the
bathrooms
[Music]
what
i